hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today it's gonna be a little bit
of a shorter one it is Thursday and then
his dead stream or your day so I'm gonna
recap this stream for you so let's get
started so first up they mentioned that
conquer Shu Bosch exploit has been fixed
basically if you don't know what it is
it caused Concord to continuously she'll
bash you and you couldn't escape until
he ran out of stamina that luckily has
now been patched so if any of you were
affected by it you know after worry
anymore
next up is week two of a polygons legacy
not much was changed but there were a
few changes the week two of the event of
the event means the enemies are going to
be getting harder so we're gonna need to
step up our game as opposed to last week
and now there's going to be seven rounds
instead of five making the fights longer
and obviously making the enemies a lot
harder because if you're unaware every
single round that you win in the in a
match of a polygons legacy in this test
your metal mode the opponents will get
harder now that you have to win four
matches they're going to be a lot more
difficult
the bosses on top of that we'll still
have feats they used on top of new ones
that they have added as well they didn't
say what the new ones were but they do
have a lot more feats that they're going
to use the community event this week is
to kill as many of a polygons followers
as possible not entirely sure what that
means maybe that just means of all the
bosses or maybe that's only in the
Knights faction who knows but that's
gonna be the community event this week
next up is the bundle packs for each
character are now available and they
will be available until March 12th so
definitely grab that while you can
they're gonna be costing $25 and steel
to get everything for the event for your
character but like I said last week if
you already have one of the items in
that bundle the price will go down so
you don't have to pay twice for it on
top of all that we're also going to be
getting an extra loot fest basically
it's to celebrate the anniversary of a
poly ons fall and we're gonna be getting
more loot they never said it was going
to be double loot we're just going to be
getting more loot than normal so also if
you want to check out my previous video
where we talked about how to get the
loot fastest for the event you could
pair that up during this weekend get
tons of loot and you could be done
probably within a few days and then to
end is the new content of the week in
the new content of the week is two free
room emotes a drinking emo and a salty
moat which I have different which have
different animations depending on the
faction of the character you choose
watch our show right now
[Music]
those are the two emotes and since two
of them are going to be released they're
gonna be 7,000 steel each for the first
week and then 10k next weeks would
definitely buy those right away if you
want there's also gonna be stuff coming
the third week but they haven't eased
anything of it yet and that's it boys
hope you guys enjoyed this really quick
video I know there wasn't a lot to talk
about on the stream but once again I
need I wanted to recap because of the
week two of the apollyon legacy and the
test your metal stuff so I thought I'd
recap it anyway as well as seeing the
new emotes now who knows if what the
third emote is going to be maybe it'll
be teased in the tester metal mode maybe
the bots will use it like how they did
with the salty moat which is how we kind
of figured out that that would be the
new emo who knows maybe that'll be the
case or maybe it's something completely
different
I have no absolute clue but with that
guys hope you guys enjoyed this really
quick video if you guys did it please
sure to give it a like leave this help
me out subscribe if we knew it cover a
lot of for honor news the patch notes
the discussion the leaks the news
everything of the informational side of
for honor I cover my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys did
want to check those out highly recommend
you do and with that guys hope you have
a great Easter day have fun in the event
and peace out